I do not believe that Donald Trump wants to
face Bernie in the democratic primary and
you can just smell Trump's fear of Bernie
Sanders being the nominee in a tweet he sent
out yesterday afternoon where he said, quote,
wow, crazy.
Bernie Sanders is surging in the polls looking
very good against his opponents in the do
nothing party.
So what does this mean?
Stay tuned.
Trump, very afraid.
By the way, the do nothing party that has
done something that was only done twice before,
which is impeached sitting president Bernie
Sanders.
By the way, tweeting back, it means you're
going to lose.
More and more people are contacting me suggesting
that if Bernie is the nominee, Donald Trump
would skip the debates.
I don't know about that and, and to be honest,
I don't think that that's a possibility.
Only if Bernie is the nominee because Donald
Trump is increasingly incoherent.
It wouldn't shock me if Trump skipped the
debates, calling them rigged and faked in
a number of circumstances with a number of
different democratic nominees.
What what it does seem though is that Donald
Trump is certainly preparing more to run against
Joe Biden as far as we know, Trump didn't
go to another country and say, I will withhold
military aid unless you get me dirt and smears
on Bernie or on Warren or whatever.
As far as we know right now, he was doing
that about Biden.
So there's the indication that he believes
he's going to be running against Biden and
to some degree has a plan for running against
Biden with Bernie.
It's going to be crazy, Bernie.
We will never be socialist.
Bernie wants to give everybody free stuff.
That's the repertoire against Bernie and I
think it falls short of what Trump has planned
for fighting Biden going after Biden about
Hunter Biden and Barisma muddling the entire
impeachment and Ukraine thing.
By pulling in what you know, Biden's involvement
there and Hunter Biden's involvement, it's
much easier for Trump to muddle it up with
Joe Biden than it is with Bernie Sanders.
Now remember that Donald Trump already started
hinting at maybe he'll debate, maybe he won't
weeks ago when he tweeted in mid, mid December.
I look very much forward to debating whoever
the lucky person is who stumbles across the
finish line and the little watch do nothing.
Democrat debates.
My record is so good on the capital economy
and all else including debating that perhaps
I would consider more than three debates.
The problem is that the so called commission
on presidential debates is stacked with Trump
haters and never Trumpers.
Three years ago, they were forced to publicly
apologize for modulating my microphone and
the first debate against crooked Hillary as
president.
The debates are up to me and there are many
options, including doing them directly and
avoiding the nasty politics of this very biased
commission.
I will make a decision at an appropriate time,
but in the meantime, the commission on presidential
debates is not authorized to speak for me
or Republicans.
So this is already on the table.
It's already something Trump is potentially
setting up in the way that his followers will
say, damn right.
He's skipping the debates.
If he chooses to, instead of being concerned
that, wait a second, why?
Why is the sitting president refusing to debate
the opponent and not some unknown third party
polling 1% but choosing to debate the winner
of the democratic primary?
That should be the reaction, but Trump is
very good at priming his supporters to cheer
on whatever decision he ultimately makes.
Also, I don't know that for our audience,
we need to get into this other part.
Trump's nickname of Bernie as crazy Bernie,
it may stick.
Trump's the power of Trump's nicknaming is,
is good, is high, but it all started with
framing Bernie as a socialist, as a crazy
far left guy.
Of course, Bernie's policies are simply called
established government policy and a lot of
Western and Northern Europe.
But it may well stick and we know the power
of Donald Trump nicknaming people.
So although to us when we see Trump say crazy
Bernie, it makes about as much sense as nicknaming
Elizabeth Warren Pocahontas and sort of the
distasteful nature of it.
But we know that Donald Trump's ability to
nickname people in ways that stick is strong.
And so I don't think we should ignore that
possibility.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram for more about this and
all other stories from today's show at David
Pakman show.
While you're there, give me a follow on Instagram
at David dot Pacman.
I posted the latest, uh, David Pakman show
hatred bingo card on my Instagram, which I
think [inaudible]
you'll enjoy.
We'll take a quick break and unfortunately
after the break I do have to play some really
sad video for you
that's
coming up next,